[Music]
it's not my son it's just a body that I
feed and wash and clothe
I'm Mary hi dr. Wilson
how's it even doing same as last week a
week before I lost him that day I lost
Richard in the car
yeah next patient he's waiting for you
in the office he's dealing with a lot of
grief after his mom died they're moving
him to Boston is that really necessary
he can just stay here it was like I had
my little boy back hi Mary hi tell you
the truth I think it'll be good for all
of us
Oh
authorities have stated the missing
child could not have survived the severe
drop in temperatures I feel so guilty
you cannot blame yourself I haven't been
sleeping that well I saw Tom but
everybody's been saying he's dead
usually problems are making it difficult
for you to distinguish your nightmares
from reality no something has happened
and Stephen has scratches on his face
listen to what you're saying you're
talking about ghosts something is going
on and it's not just in my head I can
prove it
you have to believe me
moment any answer you know they don't
apply to me that he said the rules don't
apply